i protect all of my passwords accounts
and devices using aura i get instant
alerts about threats like if my email or
password are found on the dark web so i
can fix the problem fast try aura free
for two weeks
using my link below
as i'm sure most of you would guess i
don't typically wait around for the next
episode of tucker carlson's fox news
propaganda program but i actually was
curious as to what the program would
look like last night over the weekend as
we covered yesterday there was a
horrifying terrorist mass shooting
targeting black people in buffalo new
york in which
in total uh 10 people were killed and 13
injured the 18 year old white domestic
born shooter
inspired by the ideas of the great
replacement and white birth rates that
have been just everywhere on right wing
media over the last few years the
shooter went to buffalo
looking to kill black people and indeed
he killed many black people and i was
waiting to see how is tucker carlson
going to spin it how is ben shapiro
going to spin it how is fox news going
to spin in well we immediately saw as we
looked at yesterday fox news talking
about video game violence
and continuing to fear monger about
terrorist immigrants coming over the u.s
mexico border so we saw the general fox
news approach but
the shooters manifesto
had almost verbatim language that we saw
on the tucker carlson program so the
question was what's tucker going to say
and we're going to look at clips and it
was truly a surreal episode in
absolutely every way how was tucker
going to do it how was tucker going to
separate himself how was he going to
minimize well part of it bizarrely
included talking about rwanda if you can
believe it i'm talking about the african
country of rwanda a completely i can't
think of a better term for it
kafka-esque episode of the tucker
carlson program so let's start with the
first clip in which tucker
tries to distance himself
as well as fox news from the buffalo
shooter who was of course inspired by
the conspiracy theories that tucker and
others have been pushing take a look at
this
but what he wrote does not add up to a
manifesto it's not a blueprint for a new
extremist political movement much less
the potential inspiration for a racist
revolution anyone who claims that it is
is lying well if you read it you realize
that that's exactly what it is it's
taking
the conspiracy theories that tucker and
others have been repeating on their
programs
and saying well the solution is we've
got to go and kill people who aren't
white and that's what he did read it
instead gendron's letter is a rambling
pastiche of slogans and internet memes
some of which flatly contradict one
another the document is not recognizably
left-wing or right-wing it's not really
political at all that's obviously
completely untrue because it aligns with
the exact political ideology espoused by
those
surrounding donald trump
and on this so-called
populist right where they sound all
about the middle class but then the
solutions are well we've got to do
something about these non-white
immigrants coming into the country
the document is crazy it's the product
of a diseased and organized mind and
remember
to some degree we can say there's
something mentally not working with
these folks
but as i mentioned before yesterday
the
manifesto
is quite cogent and coherent as far as
these manifestos go and writing this off
as simply mental illness doesn't make
any sense and remember most mentally ill
people never commit any violence at one
point gender suggests that fox news is
part of some global conspiracy against
him
he writes like the mental patient he is
disjointed irrational paranoid
now that's true not that it makes the
atrocities he committed easier to bear
if your daughter was murdered on
saturday in buffalo you wouldn't care
why the killer did it or who he voted
for
but the truth about peyton gendron does
tell you a lot about the ruthlessness
and dishonesty of our political
leadership
within minutes of saturday's shooting
before all the bodies of those 10
murdered americans had even been
identified by their loved ones
professional democrats had begun a
coordinated campaign to blame those
murders on their political opponents
they did it they said immediately patron
gendron was the heir to donald trump
okay so listen i am sympathetic to the
fraught nature of immediately making
political declarations that's why often
with these cases i won't cover it the
next day in this case it happened on a
weekend so we had time to the extent
that anybody before we had information
made any claims that weren't yet based
in fact that's wrong and i would
denounce that i didn't actually see that
but i also didn't pay attention to the
news on the day of i read about
everything after the fact but
the manifesto can be seen
only as an almost verbatim reproduction
of the things we've heard from tucker
and from other right-wing media now as i
mentioned earlier at one point
tucker talked about rwanda he put up a
quote from 2004 new york times about
rwanda and the rwandan genocide just i
mean completely bizarre bizarre stuff
and that an at another moment tucker
again focused on the this was just a
lone mentally ill guy that's it because
a mentally ill teenager murdered
strangers you cannot be allowed to
express your political views out loud
that's what they're telling you that's
what they've wanted to tell you for a
long time but saturday's massacre gives
them a pretext and justification so
playing on the idea that all of a sudden
now because of one mentally ill guy
completely disconnected from any
political rhetoric i mean other than the
fact that the manifesto contains
verbatim rhetoric from my show
me being speaking as tucker here
what really this is about is about
silencing your political views imagine
being so depraved or dishonest or
ignorant i don't know which it is with
tucker
to pretend that what this is really
about is simply silencing the political
speech of people like tucker who just
want to give their opinions now again
this thing of mentally ill
when you look at the manifesto
it's articulate
fascist
racist anti-semitic hate linked to ideas
that we've seen propagated by tucker and
others which we will look at again later
in the show
something is obviously wrong with people
who commit these acts of violence
but the mental illness the merely mental
illness line used to excuse the
political reality of these people's
motivations is immoral
and or dishonest
and maybe just ignorant but i have a
hard time believing that with tucker
it's ignorance so a bizarre tucker
carlson show
almost as bizarre as what ben shapiro
had to say which we're going to go to
next
i am going to show you now
the epitome of what was it in orwell's
84 it's it's like newspeak or
doublethink or
everything is reversed everything is
opposite night is day up is down etc
it is undeniable
that the alleged shooters alleged
manifesto from buffalo
supports
these ideas perpetuated
almost exclusively i mean just to be to
be conservative
99.8 percent
by right-wingers uh there's no denying
that that's the rhetoric that was in the
manifesto so ben shapiro's approach
because listen everything's coming off
the walls for these people tucker was
saying that there was nothing political
about the manifesto at all ben shapiro's
approach is okay just claim that it's
left-wing stuff claim that the great
replacement theory that we have to worry
about non-whites changing the makeup of
the country and changing who we are and
destroying
ben shapiro just goes this is a
left-wing ideology he says that great
replacement theory contains an
essentialism about race
that to him looks like left-wing
woke-ism
it's it's it's the trump thing of
don't believe what you're seeing don't
believe what you're reading just listen
to me instead check this out now the
left is trying to do is broaden out the
term great replacement theory to include
any sort of
normal concerns about illegal
immigration any suggestions that
demographic voting patterns make a
difference which of course
everybody both left and right knows that
they do i mean the left has been
claiming for literally as long as i've
been alive changing demographic patterns
in the united states we're going to
shift the politics of the country in a
progressive direction as the base of roy
teshera's the emerging democratic
majority in 2003 so now what he's doing
there is kind of slick
uh we've talked about for a really long
time
that
over a period of decades demographics
shift in a natural way
one of the things that we've observed in
that shift is that certain states in
particular southern states
are becoming
slightly more what we sometimes call
latino or hispanic and slightly less
white and we've all said that will have
an effect on elections
that is not even remotely equivalent to
what the right does which is say
we have brown people
hyper breeding they're just pumping out
children
and it's a democratic strategy to bring
illegal aliens to the country
so that then eventually they will be
naturalized and as this conspiracy
that's what the right has been saying
that's the right idea
on the left and really it's not the left
it's just in reality we go oh yeah
demographics shift over time and here's
how they're shifting
there
there's no conspiracy
to start
you know breeding hispanic women i mean
it's dystopian what they talk about and
ben shapiro wants you to believe that
it's kind of the same thing like you
know great replacement theory liberals
recognize demographic changes it's all
the same no it's not if you want to talk
about the great replacement theory and
what this person actually thought you
have to actually read the manifesto
right you actually have to know what the
great replacement theory is yeah
replacement theory is the theory that
essentially there is a there are a bunch
of jewish elites and this coterie of
jewish elites which to perverts wishes
to perverts the racial stock of a
country like the united states a
predominantly white country in order to
weaken the country from within that is
the great replacement theory it is not
concerns about illegal immigration it is
not concerns about cultural assimilation
there are great republicans of course
that's very dishonest because the
mechanism that those who are purveyors
of the great replacement theory say
democrats are using is
the bringing in of legal and illegal
immigrants i mean it's he wants to
separate the two things crazy
anti-semitic idea about jews trying to
change the demographics has nothing to
do with the immigration piece actually
no the the immigration piece is the tool
they claim is being used to affect the
change it you can't disaggregate the two
theory is the idea there can never be
cultural assimilation the great
replacement theory is the idea that
racism that race is destiny in fact the
racial essentialism of great replacement
theory looks a lot more like wokism than
it does like mainstream conservatism or
mainstream liberalism there it is guys
the great replacement theory despite
everybody espousing it being a
right-winger is actually left-wing it's
come now some people fall for this now
just as a reminder
it's all right-wingers promoting this
stuff here's tucker carlson saying that
immigration makes the country dirtier
and poorer these are right-wingers okay
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight here's a funny thing
that we noticed the other day people
debate all the time about mass
immigration
what you never hear anybody do is make
the economic case for mass immigration
but as an economic matter this is insane
it's indefensible so nobody even tries
to defend it
instead our leaders demand that you shut
up and accept this we have a moral
obligation to admit the world's poor
they tell us even if it makes our own
country poorer and dirtier and more
divided dirtier poorer and more divided
and then more tucker i mean the stuff is
straight from right wing media
i'm laughing because this is one of
about 10 stories that i know you've
covered
where the government shows preference to
people who have shown absolute contempt
for our customs our laws our system
itself and they're being treated better
than american citizens now i know
that the left and all the little
gatekeepers on twitter become
literally hysterical if you use the term
replacement if you suggest the
democratic party is trying to replace
the current
electorate the voters now casting
ballots with new people more obedient
voters from the third world now as you
can see it's not just some vague thing
it's
this is the strategy of the democrats
that's the claim that's being made just
a couple more i know i played these
yesterday but they really should be
attached here so you can see how absurd
what ben shapiro is saying is here's
charlie kirk another right winger
president joe biden's department of
defense will accept 30 000 afghan
refugees in the military installations
following the collapse of kabul
boom
political
transformation
let the country crumble do you know
there's five million displaced people in
afghanistan now
this was all intentional
joe biden let it fall apart to now say
oh i'm so sorry i guarantee you joe
biden's speech this afternoon we'll talk
about refugee assistance and relocation
support so there it is this is something
the right says democrats are doing it is
not wokism and lastly lauren beaubert
same thing yes there is um definitely a
replacement theory that's going on right
now we are killing american jobs and
bringing in illegal aliens from all over
the world world to replace them if
americans will not comply with the
tyrannical orders that are coming down
from the white house so the ideal thing
would be
to say that there's nothing in the
manifesto
that is about great replacement theory
obviously they can't do that here so the
new move is oh that's all left wing
great replacement theory is actually a
form of wokism they are just lying to
you and many of their followers are
falling for it make sure you're on my
mailing list you can sign up at
davidpakman.com that will notify you on
monday memorial day about our one day
membership special i would love for you
to join on that day just get on my
mailing list at davidpakman.com we'll
take a quick break and be right back
many people are shocked when their
identity is stolen but it's actually one
of the fastest growing crimes in the u.s
i've dealt with it it's a terrible
feeling and that's why i now protect
myself with aura one of our sponsors
aura monitors email addresses passwords
social security number bank accounts
credit cards and i can set it up to
instantly get an alert on my phone if
something happens and then aura goes
through the process of fixing it as well
aura also does things like make sure no
one's opening up bank accounts or credit
cards in your name aura takes all the
tools you need to protect all of your
accounts and devices puts them in one
easy app identity theft protection fraud
monitoring password management antivirus
all in one place at aura.com pacman you
can try aura free for two weeks you can
do things like check whether your login
credentials have been leaked the whole
world might know your email password
right now and you can find out for free
i found an old password in four
different data breaches the link is down
below
republican congresswoman liz cheney has
sort of had enough with some of her
republican colleagues she's saying to
them hey
we've just got to denounce this white
supremacy we've got to denounce this
great replacement theory stuff we need
to actually
forcefully not in a mealy mouth than
equivocating way we just need to
denounce the stuff
that has been coming from our side
that is in the buffalo shooters
manifesto and this makes her slightly
less crazy than other republicans but it
doesn't make her a political ally that's
an important thing to remember so let's
talk this through
liz cheney has reportedly
said now
that republican house leaders need to
renounce the insanity
that is sort of tied up with what the
buffalo shooter said liz cheney echoed a
growing chorus
that saturday's race-targeted massacre
in buffalo new york was a product of
rhetoric pushed by republican leaders
let's look at the tweet that she sent
where she said the house republican
leadership has enabled white nationalism
white supremacy and anti-semitism that's
correct
liz cheney is right she went on to say
history has taught us that what begins
with words ends in far worse and of
course that's what we saw in buffalo
over the weekend going on to say
republican leaders must renounce and
reject these views and those who hold
them it's not enough just to say that
you're against violence and that you're
against what the shooter did
and that you're against targeting of
black people the way the shooter did you
you can't just kind of pick around the
edges at the issue
liz cheney is accurately saying
we have to forcefully say
there is simply no place for white
nationalism white supremacy and
anti-semitism in the republican party
that's what undergirds the manifesto and
the shooting that took place in buffalo
over the weekend and republican leaders
at least so far have not been willing to
say that
now i think it's important when we talk
about liz cheney in these terms to
remind you how low the bar is liz cheney
is a complete and total trumpist by
policy well hold on what do you mean
david well if you look at 538's tracking
of liz cheney they found that in her
career
liz cheney voted 93 percent
with donald trump's position
okay 93 percent with donald trump's
position during the 115th congress it
was 96 percent during the 116th congress
it was you know 92.8 percent
she almost always
is aligned with trump or was when donald
trump was president so this is not a
political ally sometimes i say these are
not our friends and some people get mad
and they write in and say david that's
divisive language we can all be friends
maybe okay maybe we can be friends maybe
not just forget about that these are not
political allies yes liz cheney said
trump was responsible for inciting the
insurrection okay that that doesn't make
her a political ally that just means
she's marginally willing to tell the
truth about obvious things liz cheney uh
has said
donald trump really lost the election it
wasn't stolen by joe biden trump just
lost that's it it doesn't make her a
political ally 93 of the time she still
voted with donald trump during her
career and at the end of the day that's
really how we evaluate
someone's political perspective so she's
absolutely right she's correctly
pointing out that the republican
leadership has been mealy-mouthed and
unwilling to sort of in a full-throated
way just denounce the way that this
radical ideology has pervaded the
republican party and right-wing media
she's completely correct
but she still voted the way trump did uh
trump in line with trump's positions
93
of the time so it's just to remind what
what do we do with that information okay
it's a reminder
that as we think about
who
do we need
in power to achieve change
it's not going to be slightly less wacky
republicans like liz cheney that's not
where the future
of the left in the united states is it's
it's not going to be we can't count on
her
uh it's also not going to be center
right democrats like joe manchin
uh we just have to be realistic about
that that's the point i'm trying to make
here and liz cheney good for her let's
see if the republican party listens to
her they don't seem to care about what
she has to say
and let's see if they actually come out
in a full-throated way denounce this
ideology that is all over the buffalo
shooting
this is kind of interesting
we have a bunch of primaries today those
primaries today in pennsylvania there's
also primaries today in north carolina
in north carolina one of the people that
is up for um
election for re-election
is radical
trumpist republican congressman madison
cawthorn now because of madison
cawthorne's habitual law breaking and
also i guess we would call them off
color comments about washington dc about
orgies and cocaine as you might remember
he's now been caught two or three times
trying to bring guns uh through tsa
security he's had a bunch of um police
interactions involving speeding and i
don't remember if it went over to
reckless driving or not
the republican party
leadership seems to not be thrilled with
madison cawthorne and it's believed
although it has not been proven that it
is the republican party that is behind
some of these uh distasteful i guess we
would call them or videos or
compromising videos i don't even know
what term to use
uh racy videos of madison cawthorne that
have been released the idea being that
the republican party establishment is
kind of sick of cowthorn and they want
him out well he's in his primary uh
fight and that primary is today and even
though he is still winning
uh donald trump
now
seems to have come out of the woodwork
posting on truth social truth essential
yeah he calls it truth central i call it
truth social donald trump sort of uh
trying to help madison cawthorne and
defending him posting quote at 18 years
of age madison cawthorne the now 26 year
old congressman from the great state of
north carolina
went through a life-changing event the
likes of which fortunately few people
will ever have to endure
in just seconds he lost the use of the
lower half of his body a traumatic
experience to say the least that that's
true he was in a car accident terrible
when madison was first elected to
congress he did a great job
recently he made some foolish mistakes
which i don't believe he'll make again
let's give madison a second chance so
there's a bunch of funny things about
this
the first layer of this is that look at
how long donald trump waited
to make this endorsement of madison
cawthorne why did trump wait so long he
wanted to make sure he wasn't endorsing
a loser
even though madison cawthorne has lost
significant support significant support
uh for the um
uh uh from the republican party and
within his primary
it is now pretty clear that he's gonna
win the primary i would be shocked if
the polling is wrong he's still he's
ahead by less but he's still ahead i
would be shocked if he lost
trump is coming out with this the day
before the primary because trump is very
concerned with his record
and um we are now going to see
what the ultimate results are but trump
if trump doesn't particularly care about
cawthorne other than sure cawthron is a
supporter of trump trump just wants to
uh tack on wins onto his supposedly
great endorsement record which is
actually sort of mediocre that's number
one number two this is another reminder
that the norms of the republican party
trump genuinely doesn't care about them
and we sort of knew that madison
cawthorne talking about uh orgies and
cocaine and all these different things
trump genuinely doesn't care about that
and it reminds us of what early on in
the 2016 primary with the republican
party
created a rift between trump and other
republicans uh turns out that
trump will just support anybody that
supports him assuming it won't be
hurtful to trump or damaging to trump in
some way and that's exactly what we are
seeing here so we're going to follow all
of these results tonight in pennsylvania
we'll be streaming results live north
carolina will be streaming results live
i hope you'll join me we'll be live on
youtube twitch and facebook and we will
also have more on these stories on all
of our platforms including instagram
where you can find us at david pakman
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount join pacman.com
today i'm going to be speaking with greg
barrack who's the author of criminology
on trump and also emeritus professor of
criminology and criminal justice at
eastern michigan university it's really
great having you on i appreciate your
time today
thank you
so in the book you you really do an
analysis of trump and the trump family
and the presidency and the business
enterprise trump uh through through sort
of a criminology lens the idea of trump
operating as a sort of pseudo mob boss
in a sense
can you first lay out the kind of
general approach and perspective that
you used here and what and why you did
it in this way okay well i'm a
criminologist and i study crime and i
study the administration of justice and
i do so
in a very broad uh
based manner in the sense that i examine
all laws whether they be civil or
criminal uh constitutional international
so
uh he he was a perfect subject a perfect
object and and what
what what i think makes my analysis
unique or different from literally the
thousands of other books on trump
is that it is really
uh
the first and only criminal biography of
donald trump
uh
and it tries to give the 45th president
his rightful place in the history of u.s
crime
what it attempts to explain
systemically or systematically
throughout his entire life is his
uncanny ability
to get over
regardless of whether we're talking
business economics whether we're talking
politics whether we're talking
interpersonal relationships he has the
ability to
harm and abuse and to
always escape the consequences or or
almost always
escape at least criminally he's fully
escaped civilly he's been held
accountable more than once so let's
let's talk about a few examples before
he was president trump would notoriously
sue lots of people and the outcomes of
those lawsuits varied pretty
dramatically and in some cases it seemed
as though the lawsuit may have been a
tool to to maybe cover up
his own pre-existing wrongdoing can you
talk a little bit about the use of
lawsuits
right um
well
as
many of your readers may know or many of
your listeners may know
trump's mentor and surrogate father
um
was
oh jesus how am i having a blank here um
all time the mccarthy hearings
prosecutor okay
uh whose name i also don't remember
right how is this crazy
um you know where's my roy cohn roe
marcus roy marcus cohn yeah right right
okay so so cohn is his his first um
mentor and surrogate father and really
teaches him the art of weaponizing the
and the two of them over a case
involving um
housing discrimination in projects owned
by his father throughout new york
um
uh
donald retained uh cohn to represent
them and this is where it all began
for donald to use the law against the
law and to always counter sue to never
acknowledge um defeat so
that's where it first began and whether
he wins or loses a case it almost is
almost as immaterial to donald
uh because at the end of the day he will
always claim
victory
that that he won just as he won the
election he knows he didn't win the
election he knows he didn't win the
cases that he claims to but that's his
narrative can you talk about other
sometimes the the term is used that he
had a way to skirt the law in his
business career which is skirting the
law different than breaking the law
um
i i you know i can't tell you what you
know that there's any legal
meaning to the notion of skirting
the the law it's like evading the law
it's like not getting caught
um it's not really
not breaking the law he he's he's
you know engaged in lawlessness pretty
much day in and day out through various
types of business arrangements uh that
he's he he's put put together
um
what are some examples of that
well uh
the best example is the way in which
beginning with uh
uh fred senior uh
donald donald's father
that he began to transfer his enormous
wealth
to his children
some of which you could legitimately
pass on and some of which he
created shell companies that were
companies in name only he created
arrangements
where
uh
[Music]
donald and his siblings
became owners of certain companies
within the trump organization and so he
was billing them for work that he wasn't
doing
uh that that's an example donald has
continued with with that into
uh with uh at least three of his
children that were aware of uh eric and
and junior and ivanka
when we think about the trump presidency
he's really gotten away
with the most kind of basic pedestrian
just kind of shrugging off the things
that are thrown at him i mean he
recently had four cell phones subpoenaed
and he wrote i lost the phones i don't
know where the phones are what's going
to come of that we don't know probably
probably nothing uh endless requests for
documents that seem to be legitimate
requests subpoenas etc no here it's
executive privilege and there it's a
political witch hunt and it seems as
though he just gets away with it is that
in fact the way that it has gone
um
criminally
that is in fact the way it has gone okay
he's yet to be prosecuted for a single
criminal offense yes in his life so it's
certainly gone that way there in terms
of his civil litigation
he has a an impressive record maybe he's
lost 40 50 cases one three hundred the
rest have been draws
and when you say a draw
is that good for trump or good for
someone else
um it's usually good for trump okay
because you know trump has a an
interesting habit when he wins the case
you and i the taxpayers pay his
attorneys and when he loses a case he
stiffs his attorneys right right when it
comes to the current investigations you
know i have people in my audience who
are convinced i mean convinced
that at some point trump's going to face
criminal prosecution i just don't think
so and when we go through what's being
looked at right now there's the january
6th committee
who could make referrals depending on
what they find to the justice system
they could although it's not their main
charge as as described
there's the new york investigation where
we actually saw some investigators
resign because they got the impression
that there's not really any interest in
actually prosecuting donald trump you've
got the georgia investigation for
possible election fraud i mean is there
any shot any of this stuff goes anywhere
um
yeah there's always there's always a
shot that goes somewhere i i think
that what
people want to know is whether uh
attorney general emerit garland whether
or not he's going to
come come forward and you know people
have been very
wishy-washy and you know wanting this to
have occurred already
what i think is significant a couple of
things i think are significant as to why
i think he ultimately will oh
prosecute i mean i've been very
you know you know i've been mixed as to
whether he will or he won't uh in part
one sign was uh
uh eric uh former attorney general
uh eric holden
holder thank you eric holder who is an
institutionalist who for example didn't
prosecute the 10 000 uh security
fraudsters on wall street gave them all
a pass
he thought that in all likelihood
because
presidents in the past have been given
passes by
the next attorney general that this
would be the same situation with with
trump he's come around and thinks
differently now that we understand that
this was involving significant number of
elected and appointed officials and how
big the conspiracy was um
he now thinks that
you know there should be a prosecution
his change in position is significant
but i think last but not least because
of the historical situation that we find
ourselves in in terms of autocrats and
democrats and struggles in with ukraine
and russia and elsewhere
that
it becomes
rather embarrassing and it becomes a
slap in the face of so-called american
democracy when we prove that somebody
and somebodies who have power are above
the law it's not a very good marketing
tool for the united states and i think
that political pressure because it's on
the world stage
is also adding
uh substance to the fact that i think
garland is going to go after him how how
long could it take
before he
prosecutes yeah
um
in my mind
it could it could go as long as before
the primary
of um
2024 okay i mean the problem is
if they go after him
and if he can keep
the delays from the actual trial
occurring
before the primary begins then he'll be
able to probably sidestep whether he
wins or loses 20 24 because i'm
convinced that whether he loses or not
he they will the republicans and company
will actually steal the election so
therefore he can keep
the
attorney general
and the justice department away from him
to 2029. wait so i don't want to go i
don't want to miss something you just
said that's a big deal
you believe that in 24
the the sort of trial run that was 2020
some of those different ideas that were
floated for how to take an election they
didn't win you think they might
successfully use those tools in 24. i
think they're well on their way they
have control of
26 out of the 50 state
legislative bodies who could and are in
fact preparing themselves
to overturn the election
wow
um okay let's come back to that uh the
um
many
armchair mental health professionals
during the trump era
would maybe not diagnose but suggest
that donald trump
could be
narcissistic
that he might be delusional that he's
self-deluded that he's mentally ill in
different ways that he lies
uncontrollably pathological lies etc one
of the things that you write if i
understand it correctly is that while
all of those things may be true
you don't believe that any of it is the
sort of explanation or ultimate cause of
the criminality and the lying and the
deception that in that sense he knows
what he's doing am i am i accurately
summarizing your position you are spot
on that's exactly what we are arguing he
is a rational player he may be
you know suffering from a variety of
mental illnesses but when it comes to
his day-to-day affairs he is a rational
player he clearly knows that he did not
win the election he is not
self-deluded for a moment he's a con a
performance artist and he's just doing
the script so how do you know that and i
guess with like the election thing as an
example i've gone back and forth over
time does trump think he won the
election or does he know that it's that
he didn't really win
and i was kind of on the side of he's
lying it's a con
but more recently we've had reports from
behind the scenes that he was privately
talking to people and saying that he won
which doesn't sound like something he
would do if he knew he didn't really win
it depends on who he's probably talking
to
he wouldn't say that to jared he
wouldn't say it to ivanka but he would
say it to
um
the people who have all been subpoenaed
for example like mark meadows for
example he would keep up the lie with
mark meadows he would keep up the lie
with those people i mean jared knows
better
um you know he he knows a lot you know
it wasn't stolen just like bannon knows
it wasn't stolen
so then you're so so your
assertion is
when it comes to
the audience that needs to hear the lies
trump knows he's not telling the truth
oh absolutely absolutely that's why he's
such a great performer
um
when it comes to
zooming out a little bit now
sure uh one of the conversations that
took place a bunch of times while trump
was president was
are our checks and balances sort of like
robust enough
and
one of the kind of answers that was
zeroed in on was
generally speaking they are but the
founding fathers never imagined
someone like trump would be elected and
that's why
there aren't more checks and balances
that would have prevented some of the
things that donald trump did what what's
your sense of that it did the checks and
balances fail
um i'm not sure the checks and balances
um were were
were tested until now
right
you know so so and they clearly
it remains to be seen
whether or not
they work or they don't work from my
perspective
with respect to the the popular
story or
uh
explanation that the founding fathers
never thought
that an oligarch or that some you know
very wealthy person
could be doing similar things to donald
um
i they knew about kings
i mean they knew about the danger
of of of the parties reverting back you
know they didn't care for parties but
yeah so i i don't buy that but you know
i'm i'm
not
that much of an expert to know fair fair
the book is criminology on trump we've
been speaking with the book's author
greg barrack who's also emeritus
professor of criminology and criminal
justice at eastern michigan university
uh so appreciate your time today thank
you so much
thank you david
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month
check it out at
patreon.com david pakman show i'm going
to play a video for you today
that i know many of you will think has
to be fake it has to be a comedy skit it
has to be satire it must be from
saturday night live and it's not
i'm going to play a clip for you today
of a mom interviewed on fox news
who is suing
suing her son's school
because her son will no longer do chores
at home because he's been taught
critical race theory apparently her son
is half black she says in a new york
post article that her son looks um
hawaiian
and she says all of a sudden because of
critical stuff that her son has been
taught he won't do chores around the
house anymore i it is
unbelievable look at this all right so
melissa your your son is uh the father's
black you're white and
he'd never mentioned issues with race
before you're saying what exactly
changed
right we didn't have issues before he's
in eighth grade they introduced this
critical
program and they introduced the critical
program and all of a sudden what
happened listen to this and now he's
having racial issues that was not there
before what kind of racial issues is he
having
well he's seen himself just as a black
man he's seen things that don't go as
way as racism
um and he's finding safety in numbers
now
so he's finding safety in numbers i
would love to explore that more you're
saying he gets a bad grade at school he
blames racism or
a girl rejects him on a date racism are
those the kind of things you're seeing
yes i ask him to clean the house racism
yeah
you're kidding right are you serious
no i'm serious they have totally changed
his perspective
can you imagine
hey um you you're supposed to vacuum
that's racist mom hey i'm your mom it's
time to vacuum i mean it's you're suing
the school
because it's i i can't get
how is this a real segment it's very
difficult to believe that this isn't a
plan i actually thought
this is going to be another one you know
when these people prank fox news and it
turns out that it's actually a complete
and total joke like there was this
famous one we interviewed the guy max
rice who went on fox and he pretended
that he was a former obama voter who
didn't who wanted to vote for romney
instead because of some he lost a bet it
was like this whole fake thing and later
it came out it was all a joke
i wrongly assumed this was going to be a
joke
and the there's one other part one
possibility is the mom has completely
lost control of just parenting like she
doesn't know how to parent that's one
possibility the other possibility is
that this is sort of like made up or
exaggerated
and she's using her kid as a political
pawn like at some point don't you say
listen you've you've just got to do your
homework you've just got to do your
chores i'm i'm the parent i'm in charge
here and she goes on an international
news outlet which i can't imagine is
going to make circumstances that much
better for her kid in school as well
that it just strikes me that that's not
going to be a particularly useful thing
and then again in this new york post
article that was written about this you
know new york post it's not a source we
typically use but that's where she was
she was interviewed
virginia's school virginia schools
anti-racist program has changed my son
mom says
uh and she did say he looks hawaiian
he's beautiful
he didn't used to see himself as
different from other kids sure his skin
tone was a little darker his dad is
black
and right i guess the mom is white and
native american but she never wanted to
box him in with stifling racial
classifications and now an anti-racist
curriculum
she says is itself racist because it
indoctrinates students and teachers in a
racial
essentialist world view
this is really wacky stuff if it wasn't
so sad and dangerous
and disheartening it would be funny
because it seems like comedy but it's
not and i would expect a lot more of
this over the next few years
melania trump not someone we typically
talk about but she gave her first
major interview since leaving the white
house as a failed first lady
this is an interview on fox news that i
have to tell you
north korean broadcasters who do north
korean state media
they would see this in blush and go this
is too fawning of an interview you have
to see this
one of the big questions from pete
heggseth to melania was
given how attractive you are and
successful in business
isn't it biased that you haven't been on
the cover of people magazine this is an
interview folks yes how did you put up
with the constant criticism the media
take uh vogue for example
five months into joe biden's president
joe biden's on the cover kamala harris
is on the cover before she's even sworn
in hillary clinton was on the cover when
she was first lady right michelle was on
the cover three times
yet
with your business background and your
fashion background and your beauty
never on the cover of vogue why i mean
is there a more possible question that
you could imagine that a question that's
more fawning than this double standard
they're biased
and um
they have likes and dislikes and it's so
obvious and i think american people
and
everyone see it
it was their decision and
i
have much more important things to do
and we don't know what those things are
but she apparently has more important
things to do
this is indistinguishable from a
scripted state media interview
um she said she she did enjoy living at
the white house i like washington dc
i know it operates completely different
than any other city
but
i really like it there and i enjoyed
living in the white house to be first
lady of the united states was my
greatest honor i think we achieved a lot
in the four years can you think of
anything melania achieved i can't think
of one single thing of trump
administration i
enjoyed taking care of the white house
it was
my home for a while
i understood it it is people's house
it was
it was a privilege to live there and
maybe it'll be your home again
never say never right never say never
she may be back
uh she took the fox and friends
interview as an opportunity to promote
her nfts which i still don't even
understand what they do or what they're
for and i kind of know a little bit
about this space and i have no clue what
what it's about so you're using a new
technology to help
raise the profile and fund these
initiatives i have been working on my
nfd projects
since i left the white house my nfts
they are available on melaniatram.com
and usmemorabilia.com
and now we have a few of the nfts that
they are meeting on it
it's a national park beautiful 3d
animated
pieces it's hard to imagine something
more inspirational than a 3d animated
melania nft isn't it and potus trump
there are pictures and animated videos
from our time in the white house and
especially the one that i created
for foster care month it's uh the rose
the meadows some of the proceeds of the
sales of nfts will go towards
education providing education
opportunities for foster care children
who are ageing out of
foster system
yearly 20 000 children are aging out of
foster care a year a year yes and now we
have 400 7 000
children in foster care system in
america today so i will what a
hard-hitting interview here and then
lastly
she suggests her critics
maybe instead of criticizing her
um just help help foster kids okay well
people
i see always criticize me whatever i do
and i'm used to that
i move forward
and i'm here to helping people and that
is the mission
and those people who criticize me i
would encourage them to help in their
own community or maybe join my foster
the future initiative there you go so if
you were criticizing melania instead
do something to help the foster kids
what did we learn in this interview i
think we learned about the technique of
the completely meaningless
worthless
pointless
endless
softball interview that is uh within the
scope of what pete hegseth on fox news
can do uh again you look at chinese
state media uh you look at saudi state
media russia today
you look at north koreans kcna
they would see this and go that oh man
that's a little too fawning even for us
we we at least pretend to ask a real
question pete hegseth didn't bizarre
stuff and uh there is melania in case
anybody was sort of anxiously waiting to
see what she had to say now
that she's out of the white house
i hope that it was satisfying to hear
from her we have a voicemail number and
that number is 2192 david p here's a
caller who is understandably confused
about the great replacement theory stuff
espoused by the buffalo shooter take a
listen to this
hey david that shooter in buffalo cited
great replacement theory
that makes no sense to me because it's
not like
black people in this country for the
most part are immigrants i know some are
but
they their their ancestors were
forcefully
immigrated immigrated over here you
could say but i just don't see the logic
how he would use that as an excuse to
kill that particular demographic i don't
either um
do they actually believe that
black people are being
sent in here by democrats or something
so here's what you have to understand
it's a great point which is great
replacement theory is focused on forcing
demographic changes upon the united
states through immigration
but for the most part the people that
are coming to the united states legally
and illegally are not black people as
traditionally defined so why would you
go and shoot black people if you're
angry about great replacement theory all
you have to understand is this
for a lot of these folks there's white
people
and then there's everybody else so it
doesn't matter that great replacement is
more about the immigration of what you
know what we might call brown latino
hispanic people and the shooter went and
targeted black people it's just it's all
non-white people now there's sometimes
an exception there's something called
the ideal immigrant story about asian
folks
so sometimes these same people who are
angry about
black brown people coming to the united
states
in order to try to justify
themselves not actually being racist
xenophobes they'll go
we're fine with people coming from and
they'll usually list asian countries
they'll say like south korea and stuff
like that this is this is called the
model minority or the ideal minority uh
it's it's another trope that's often
part of this so but generally speaking
there it's if it's not white people
that's their concern and so
that's the connection between great
replacement and black folks even though
it doesn't actually make much sense
since most black folks are indeed
born here in the united states i i'm
trying to explain something that doesn't
make sense
so i hope i've at least explained what
they believe accurately we have a great
bonus show for you today we are going to
talk about a dutch doctor that will keep
sending abortion pills to american women
we will explain how north korea went
from zero covid to 1.2 million cases in
just 72 hours
and we will talk about a supreme court
decision that will make ted cruz a half
a million dollars richer all of those
stories and more on today's bonus show
sign up at joinpacman.com if you're
waiting for our big memorial day
membership discount you can get on our
newsletter at davidpakman.com and on
monday memorial day you'll get an email
telling you how to sign up at a massive
discount
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors i protect all of
my passwords accounts and devices using
aura i get instant alerts about threats
like if my email or password are found
on the dark web so i can fix the problem
fast try aura free for two weeks using
my link below